[Music]
welcome one and all to the h3 podcast
experience how's that look pretty good a
light ex perience we got super powers
over here this is our [ __ ] experience
I don't see Joe Rogan's
podcasts lighting up with a reverb and
lightning bolt he'll know I'm good thank
you to quip Dollar Shave Club and
fortnight for sponsoring this episode of
the HP podcast guys we started late
today because my day so far has been
pretty messed up oh my god what happened
so having breakfast this morning you
know getting ready for the day and I see
shredder on his little bed next to the
breakfast table chewing on this weird
little blue thing and I'm like what the
hell is that
what does what a shudder gotten himself
into and he's like he's the pickiest
eater in the world he doesn't eat
anything but this little thing of course
he'd eat this and I pick it up and what
I end up seeing I thought it was like
maybe a piece of detergent or something
but what ended up being was a freaking
adderall pill ooh that was like covered
in plastic and he was like much like
halfway through it so I'm online looking
up like what is this I'm like it's
adderall who-who the hell left adderall
on my floor so I call the vet the vet
says call poison control poison controls
like well he's a little guy and the
amount that he ate pretty much crosses
right over the line of being toxic so
they're like you need to take him to the
vet immediately and induce vomiting and
shove charcoal down his throat and I'm
looking at this sweet little guy by the
way shredder who's the light of my
life beside the ELA you know
whoops and I'm like dude this guy's
gonna go through like the craziest day
they're gonna go pump his frickin
stomach so I get in the car because he
seems fine he just basically ate a bunch
of crack was what adderall's so I'm in
the car driving on the way to the vet he
seems fine at halfway there he starts
shaking and like crying and he's
confused he's like panicked and it's
like apparent that the drug had had
started affecting him and I'm and I'm
like crying cuz I'm so frickin scared
for my little guy and ILA's out of the
country out of the country with her
family
it's a anyway we get to the vet he's
fine they pumped his stomach he's fine
he's a sweet little guy point is sorry
I'm late my little guy almost went
though I don't know if I can handle that
the government just break you man well
he I was talking to Eli about it and
she's like if anything happened to
shredder I swear to God I I couldn't
handle that she's like I couldn't handle
I know what I do cuz she's over there
taking care of her of her father who's
sick right now whoo anyway he's fine
yeah but who walks around with an
adderall in their pocket just free
flying just free flying in the pocket
any small creature that comes across the
vet said when he puked
they found the the pill was blue and
they found all these little blue specks
like a ton of the drug in his stomach
she said it's a good thing you brought
him right away cuz he puked it out and
he I think he would have died certainly
if I didn't catch him eating it right
away he would have died crazy so anyway
so that's about that that's why we're
late I don't know if that was an
interesting story but I'm I was I was
very upset but he's okay now and I'm
also I'm the Wizard of loneliness this
week because ela is gone she
is back helping her family and I am
truly the Wizard of loneliness shredder
was gone with my parents the other day
and I just sitting there damn cast
loneliness on myself
level 99 but anyway I'm here to
entertain and that is what I shall do
next Friday is the great and wonderful
Bo Burnham which we are all super
excited to meet and chat with him and
we're going to talk about his amazing
film that's coming up very excited about
that
but we've got a lot to get to today
we've got the tanah con con it took me a
while to wrap my head around the tannic
on thing this was like a roller coaster
of fraud the thing about Tanika I've
seen a lot of people talking about it
the thing that kind of surprised me most
about it I'm not a lawyer I have dealt
with a lot of legal stuff though is that
I'm like damn like they're off being
like yeah I [ __ ] up but a lot of
people aren't acknowledging that it
seems to be criminal fraud like straight
up like the FBI might want to say what
up to her and a couple of weeks from now
I want to get into that but first let's
break the ice because I've got a clip
that might be the best thing I've ever
seen I'm just gonna pop that up there
get the mood set get the feeling right
ma'am being in the trenches solos a
[ __ ] brutal dude but here we go no
sound oh there's no sound on this so
this is there's no sound on this right
down
no no so basically what you're seeing is
there's a I think they were shoplifting
right there shoplifting and they try to
escape us a police officer he brings her
to the down he brings her down they're
all kind of doing having a little orgy
there at the entrance kind of just
hustling around so dude escapes from the
police he's running into the storage the
basically the back area where they store
all the soda pops as you can see now
this video is so perfectly like shot and
set
and the twists and turns in it he's
throwing halls at the officer the
officer has a gun pointed at him what
does he do he arms himself with a bag of
halls lost and well I'm getting ahead of
myself by the way these police officer
pants are kind of Gucci is [ __ ] they got
nice taping on the leg it's pretty
stylish how did she escape
this isn't Canada by the way if you need
to know if this was an America they'd be
[ __ ] bleeding dead on the floor it
Canada this girl's just wandering around
you know what I mean
there's two officers and she's still
wandering around the store anyway he's
armed Oh little taser there straight to
the floor did I miss the bat though oh
yeah here this [ __ ] arms himself
with what does it say spritz they look
like a bag of peanuts or something here
you go
if you take one step closer man I'm
gonna hit you with this bag of peanuts
his threats sadly did not avail as the
officer was was better armed than him
sadly so he's pretty much in submission
but nope he got a second wind folks he's
got a second one and his his wife is on
the loose and he points to her says back
the [ __ ] off [ __ ] is what he said
now I yeah that that was a that was a
real spill I've wondered if this video
is fake but that spill is real folks let
me tell you that was oh he's got he's
got his knee right on his [ __ ] dick
bone there I think pretty so the girl
has got a she's like you know listen the
cop just need my boyfriend the dick he's
probably impotent from now on so she's
like I don't have any much use for this
guy so I'm out of here
peace she tries to sneak out and that's
true love folks she's like he's [ __ ]
I'm out of here
peace
there's the bag of spritz that was
thrown at the officer those re those
aren't evidence no Exhibit C dude this
guy man
this officer this is like a real test
for him like how do you stop a meth head
in Canada it's a lot harder to enforce
the law when you don't have a gun you
know if this was America they would have
just executed that guy you'd be done a
short video kind of sad because instead
of having like a wonderful almost three
stooge asked video doing joy it would
just be like drugged homeless man was
shot dead by Florida me you know but
instead we've got this wonderful little
and it gets better folks stay tuned I
love the effort by this officer though
he's like you will not [ __ ] escape me
meanwhile back at the ranch his uh his
wife having decided to divorce him is
looking for an escape route she goes to
the ceiling desperation my god now this
is like dude how the hell did they
capture this so perfectly that's what
makes me suspicious of it being fake
like you even get the ass shot in there
in the spandex and not saying that's
something that interests me just simply
stating that it is quite an
opportunistic shot well where is she
where'd she go let's find out having a
tussle and then suddenly look who's back
that's right the girlfriend she's back
she's back ladies and gentlemen and
aren't we so glad that the Canadian
police force in this very moment aren't
armed and we can enjoy this video the
way she pops back up to it's just so
beautiful she what dude they must be
drugged out of their mind cuz she just
was like shrugs it off like it's nothing
let's get it let's get it let's get it
slow definitely let's go to quarter
speed on this one shall we
so as you can see she's crawling around
the attic space trying to look for an
out and maybe maybe she had second
doubts maybe she said you know what I do
love oh you think she was trying to do
like an aerial assault
hey yeah she's trying to help out but
not quite not quite there's tennis balls
rolling all over the place man she was
just unharmed whatever they're on I'll
have one please Christ I could use a
little invincibility my life I could
barely go up my stairs in that evening
but be that as it may she's not wearing
shoes either which i think is
interesting to point out I know she is
well she's missing one shoe she is
missing one shoe which is definitely
worth pointing out I wonder if she's
headed on over to the peanut bags to try
to defend her boyfriend stuck up on the
emo stack up on ammo she's like listen I
listen I don't know the guy I didn't do
anything man yeah okay and then then
then the real the real mf'er show up and
put an end to this rodeo but wasn't that
a thrill wasn't that a thrill ladies and
gentlemen truly a gift from Canada and I
just really want to reflect one more
time on and enjoy the fact that they are
armed with Tasers or not live maybe
they're I don't know but they ain't
shoot them so cheers to that
yeah what a thrill that's a beautiful
thing man it's like do you see what I'm
saying though it's almost so perfectly
arranged right that it that I'm very I
am so much a suspicion but the way they
eat [ __ ] you really can't fake that
right like like how do you fake that
that's a real spill how do you fake that
she can't she takes back-to-school
shopping sales very seriously that face
when uh
that face when school paper is 50% off
me once when school supplies are 50% off
you know let's see that again
really can't get enough one more for
posterity this is totally me when I see
that am/pm has a special on school
supplies this is me watching that all
week and still Craig Smith well cheers
to them you know what nobody was hurt
nobody was murdered it was a beautiful
oh it's just every once in a while you
get a video this is just so so perfect
alright well now that I got that out of
the way we should move on to the Tana
calm now I know a lot of you guys
probably been following the tannic on
thing I think a lot of people have
talked about it by now so I don't want
to get too much into the the nitty
gritty honestly what I was trying to do
cuz I was going through all this
information last night and the and the
preceding week we just understand like
what the hell happened so I kind of have
things bullet pointed I've got video
clips I got pictures and I and I think
there's there's a lot of interesting
stuff in here but most importantly well
let's start from the beginning okay
let's start here I this is a riveting
story by the way this whole thing is
just absolutely fascinating and I
haven't said fascinating in a while and
trust me when I say that I mean he's he
fascinating fascinating that up quick so
she so Tana was pissed that VidCon
hadn't given her featured creator badge
in previous years so she won having that
so she decided to start her own
convention that was inclusive for
everyone that's what she kept pressing
is that it was inclusive for everybody
she sold these VIP passes that said
featured creators on them it's like but
every person there is a featured creator
featured [ __ ] creator so it actually
said [ __ ] believe that it did the actual
official name is featured [ __ ] create
that is so [ __ ] cool but it's like
dude yeah let's be real
she sold 5,000 tickets and they are all
feature craters let's be real there's
only one featured creator at tanah con
it's Tana she wasn't there apparently so
Tana decides to throw a con to rival
VidCon with like 30 to 45 days to plan
it all right so here here's the original
invite from the production company
called good times which a lot of good
info about these boys but let's start
with this welcome creators we are so
thrilled for you to be a part of the
first-ever Tanic on good times is a
family that celebrates the online
community we are so honored to be
hosting this event
we truly believe that each of you here
is equip are equipped with so many
talents and passions to lead a
revolution
tone it down Doug you're charging $65
for a VIP ticket there's not a
revolution through the social media
world that fosters a vibrant inclusive
and world changing environment I hate
this whole sentiment of like everybody's
a featured [ __ ] creator you're all
YouTube superstars there it's actually
really exploitive because you know every
kid these days wants more than anything
to be a youtuber at Micon everybody is a
featured [ __ ] creator for $65 this
event is pioneering the change that we
are community wish to see in this
industry oh yeah we definitely need more
more tan icons we strive to make this a
community where everybody feels seen
heard understood and most importantly
included don't they understand it in a
world where everybody's included it's
like you don't exist
Tanna when everybody's like equal and
everyone has the same talents and appeal
it's like you don't exist it's so
disingenuous everyone is a featured
[ __ ] creator so with that being said
[ __ ] VidCon [ __ ] the current CEO is this
voice working for you as a cringy you I
mean it's no more engineer than her
voice that's
but everyone who created VidCon and if
you want to know why Tana Conte became a
thing and that's why all the love this
is a great genesis of like a great
mission statement it's so phony dude
it's a phony [ __ ] ever you're all
featured creators I got to tell you I
you've got probably know so we don't
really post videos on h3 anymore I just
I'm so like well there's a lot of
reasons why we're but one of the big
reasons just like man I just I really
just can't watch everything on YouTube
it's just I don't know man it's all
gotten so Tana it's like all Tana people
like her so um let me see what we got
here what is this I'm not sure what this
this significant of that one is what is
this Dan first of all from Shane's
documentaries a clip of her vlog I think
that video was just for some reason
timestamp wrong just go to the very
beginning of that video and it it's a
nice little summary of her permission
statement all of the people and all of
the unwanted people should host a little
meet-and-greet in Anaheim California on
the same days as VidCon I'd love to do
it
I would love to charge you all $65 to
come to this rebellious little
convention of ours hmm which stick it to
them we'll stick it to those capitalists
at VidCon it gets so good so anyway
she's selling so what she actually
pitches is that most of the tickets are
gonna be free and there's only gonna be
a few VIP tickets what is essentially a
free event people who buy VIP tickets
get to skip the line they get three
times worth the ticket price and a
goodie bag
so the VIP tickets were $65 so
essentially she's saying the goody bags
can be worth about 200 bucks okay so
let's go ahead and look through the
goodie bag that the VIP people get and
guys really stick around here so this
this was the the most prominent probably
the most valuable item and there what
the [ __ ] I paid $20 for a condom there's
an a condom oh yeah 75 comes dyslexic so
looks like a it's kind of packaged like
a after-dinner mint you know what's the
best part about them giving out condoms
is that everyone there's 12 that's good
but also imagine actually using this
condom and then finding out that it does
it's not a real condom when it breaks
you know like is there a little
disclaimer that's like this is actually
after-dinner mint packaging and not
meant to conceal something as important
as a condom I wonder how many like
unplanned births or or infectious
diseases were passed
thanks to her tan a condom by the way
isn't so good that like con the tannic
on is just like so good anyway that was
the that was basically the highlight of
the good of the $200 goodie bag here's a
video of a girl unboxing her goodie bag
I love it included some broke-ass Gucci
princess $0.99 like wristband like okay
it's so sketchy princess do you think
that any of these little girls spending
$65 for your VIP pass can afford Gucci
[ __ ]
the whole I don't even know this is
cruelty free shopping guy yeah clearly
it's just a bunch of garbage
I mean it's essentially they basically
put a bunch of [ __ ] in a bag and said
will you throw this out for us so but it
gets good folks here let's let's keep
going so the day of its pure chaos
outside nobody gets into the convention
which turns out to be by the way just a
Maria events room that has a maximum
capacity of a thousand and the creators
can't even get into the room because
it's so unsafe because it's so chaotic
and uncontrolled outside here let me
give you a view of basically here let's
see this doesn't look so yeah you can
see there's just like a winding it's
like the whole parking lot I mean nobody
can get inside no it's there's like
4,000 people outside or something like
that yeah
so the funny part about basically this
is that thousands of people are outside
okay
and they're supposed to be a VIP ticket
line for people who got the VIP ticket
to skip in front of the free tickets but
everybody out there who's waiting in
line for four to six hours in the
blazing heat without any food or water
being offered there's actually footage
of ambulance and fire trucks coming and
rescuing people from getting heatstroke
everybody who's outside is starting to
realize they all have a VIP ticket
because it was pitched like mostly free
and maybe like 300 VIP for people who
really care and want to make sure they
meet everyone so everybody out there
they're starting realize has a VIP
ticket they start claiming that there
was 20,000 people outside this is the
genius that organized the event this
[ __ ] 20 or old I don't even know what
to say about you dude I can't really say
anything I honestly can't say anything
but what do you need to say what really
do you need to say this
is the guy that organized this event
what really do you need to say about a
guy like this yeah
well as Dan affectionately put it the
Segway can and this is just perfect
this is this is the guy organizing the
event this [ __ ] guy with a scarf like
oh yeah once I put a scarf on
everybody's gonna know that this is
under control except you made a huge
mistake you drove a [ __ ] Segway
around dude god gee-whiz man this is a
guy in charge something special about
the scarf when it's like 95 degrees
outside people are passing out yeah
exactly so they start gloating so it's
it's chaos it's pandemonium outside
nobody can get in people are having
heatstroke
you know and there start Tanna starts
tweeting [ __ ] like there's 20,000 people
outside we only 5,000 people were to
show we're supposed to show up but
there's 20,000 15,000 unregistered
guests showed up to the convention and
that's why we have to shut it down
here she says that Bela Bela and I are
coming out to talk to everyone
everything is fine just fire marshals
stuff keeping it safe maybe I won't do
that voice adding a third day or if
worst comes to worst I would be down to
personally refund anyone who's still
upset no one expected 20,000 people my
love's I love you
so she's just like no big deal 20,000
people showed up everyone understands
but the thing is that the police report
issued that same day says there was four
thousand four to five thousand people
there at max four to five thousand
people at max which turns out is the
exact number of VIP tickets they sold so
literally the same amount of people
showed up as bought tickets and they're
trying to paint it like twenty thousand
people showed up and that's why we're
shutting it down but the truth is they
over so
the convention with a 1000 seat capacity
to 5,000 people here's the police report
because Tana and this production company
kept trying to spin this narrative of
like so many people show up that's why
we had to shut it down so here's the
actual official police report Garden
Grove police department officers were
sent to Marriott suites hotel to assist
hotel staff and security with crowd
control and dispersal of unruly hotel
guests from the hotel property
the Tanner Kong Convention was an event
hosted by tan account company at the
Marriott suites hotel the organizing
group for tenant Kahn was a company
called good times promotion promotions
event was scheduled to have meet and
greet sessions between YouTube
celebrities and their fans their concert
concerts and DJ schedule performed for
fans in the bar room starting at 1:00 or
10:00 a.m.
Tana Kahn had sold approximately 4,000
tickets at the time of the event the
skip on down the hotel ballroom where
the event was scheduled could hold a
maximum of 1,000 people the organized
planned the organizers plan to move the
crowd in and out of the venue to allow
all attendees the opportunity to
participate in that as the crowd moved
through the venue they were herded into
the lobby after a short time to allow
other fans into the ballroom people
moved into the lobby where upset and
refused to leave as the crowd grew in
the lobby hotel staff and event security
could not gain compliance from the fans
so they're like overflowing into the
hotel lobby but essentially what's
important is that the police
specifically state that there was four
to five thousand people there
approximately 20 officers and several
supervisors responded to the scene dude
wasting the time of like essentially an
entire police force to disperse this
absolute mess the police supervisors on
CN estimated the crowd was between four
to five thousand social media sites said
the crowd was twenty thousand and this
was not accurate police officers were
made we're able to disperse the crowd
after approximately 60 to 90 minutes so
there you go
the exact amount of people showed up as
tickets sold
who could have predicted yeah who would
have ever seen that coming
this is the part I want to show this one
scene yeah this this is really important
scene here this is from Shane's
documentary what'd she do a lot of the
legwork on this and it's really good but
this is footage they took while they
were planning the Vic their con so here
listen to this I haven't said it fifty
two hundred right now no capacity
[Music]
everything god I love that for us so
he's like the hotel is set at a thousand
but I have it set at fifty two hundred
and she bears witness to that and says I
love that for us which is basically
conspiracy to commit fraud but they're
straight up just acknowledging that
they're over selling the event by four
thousand seats this is the part at the
end of Shane's documentary where he's
just like here's the here's the raw
facts so here you go so I still had a
lot of questions about pretty much
everything so I called Michael Michaels
D the Michael's the event organizer
secondly dude yeah the Segway kid the
official number of VIP tickets sold was
five thousand one hundred
the number of free tickets was between
two and three hundred
well that's inclusivity baby we just
think that everybody's a featured
[ __ ] creator as long as you pay me
$65 I'm surprised 300 people got free
tickets claims that Hannah knew that and
that she was lying when she said she
might ana still says she didn't the
number of security guards was never 91 I
got a hold of the contract and it said
that at most there was 25 security
guards and I gotta put that perspective
for most conventions it's usually 50
guards per 5,000 people so this was cut
in half the amount of money spent on
security was sixty thousand dollars to
put that in perspective the amount of
money that VidCon spends on security is
1 million dollars stings so I gotta fold
it the contract between the Marriott and
good times and the contract stated that
there was only going to be one thousand
and Michael signed it
now I'm not Anna and Michael about this
and they both said that yes the contract
might have said it thousand but
everybody at Marriott told them that
that was just a safe number and that
five thousand okay okay
that's so stupid there's they literally
had a room with a max capacity Dan you
you've worked with like with a lot of
venues and stuff if they tell you oh
yeah they're like it's a thousand
maximum capacity but that's just no
[ __ ] way are you kidding me no way no
way in hell that's real just also
whatever that's kind of a big [ __ ]
difference from 1,000 like maybe 1,300
but like yeah I got it over maybe but
even then though they would never they
would even if they would like turned a
blind eye to it they would never say
that because they're liable like that
that's insane its Marriott it's like
huge corporation they're not gonna be
like oh yeah 5,000 that's fine
that's the part it's Marya it's not some
amateur small hotel they don't give a
[ __ ] about Tana you know like they do
they have events there every day it's
this is just routine to them and it's
just know there's no way that's real I
mean this this is the part that really
like your he is saying the capacity is
1200 even if there was no issues no
drama no whatever it wouldn't have
worked there's no way that's five
thousand two people could fit there
there's no way that five thousand people
would have had what is my goal for you
this wasn't gonna work but I haven't
said it fifty two hundred right now why
should be looking there like a mom you
know she's twenty that blew me away dude
she's twenty she looks like she's going
on her second marriage already why she
like coked out like she's like rubbing
or knows everything about em hmm so
anyway the thing that that really like
just actually acts me about this is that
Shane Shane did an amazing job on this
documentary like showing all this I mean
he did not more lunches yeah but in a
way it is also a way for them to save
face and be like we confronted it we
talked about it but the truth is they
straight or appear to be committing a
fraud they collected like three hundred
and twenty five thousand dollars from
these kids the convention by the way
completely shut down like nobody got in
and here's a great part nobody's been
refunded
nobody's been refunded here check out
this press release apparently this G the
Segway kid the genius in a contract he
signed with this like startup ticketing
company said that they will not issue
refunds any any under any condition and
that any refunds would be at have to be
handled by them directly it's a great
policy it's fantastic and in here if you
would will be issuing refunds to make a
claim please go to good times dot live
slash claims and fill out the form
anytime before January fifth you
should expect a refund within the next
30 days it's like bro you got a you
gotta jump through hoops and pray that
you get a refund but the worst part is
like a lot of people flew they're booked
hotel rooms for this and these guys
pretty much committed like a straight-up
criminal fraud I would not be surprised
if the FBI are pleased for it come knock
another door in like a couple weeks so I
don't know yeah there's no way this is
over for them I don't think so they're
in deep [ __ ] yep there's some great
little details here too like the same
night that that all went down and the
convention was closed and everyone was
losing their minds look at this this is
her that evening she's a Gucci's
princess thanks for your $65 anyway so
Wow
well you know what really shocked me the
most mmm cuz they you know this girl
Bella Thorne that she's friends with
they're both 20 dude that's more
mind-blowing than even the fraud itself
those girls and I I don't know if this
comes off rude it probably might but and
they're those girls have a lot of
mileage on them they're like 20 going on
30 like holy [ __ ] and I'm not saying
that like Bella Thorne isn't attractive
I'm just saying she needs her oil
changed at this point I just went ears
old alright she looks good she looks
good it just looks like she's what she
just washed out of the seat Tanna
I don't know I just shocked that she's
20 I'm not saying they're they're you
know ugly or anything just goddamn well
it explains a lot about
all of this and I believe the the
Michael kid the the Segway kid he's also
20 or maybe 21 what happened it's a
bunch of children yeah what happens when
a bunch of 20 year old pseudo
celebrities try to organize a convention
here it is you get a little fraud a
little unplanned pregnancy a couple of
STDs have you ever had a condom break on
you Dan I have actually yeah that's
that's a scary it's a bad feeling oh
yeah a lot of people are gonna be
busting through those did breaking
through a con is one of the worst things
ever I remember the first time I had sex
what the condom broke
the first time the very first [ __ ]
you're like oh [ __ ] you're like this is
a good condom like this is a really good
condom damn what's this brand again damn
baby what's this brand oh it's a tannic
on brand like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] do you
have to plan B it i flying beat it yeah
have you planned beat it the time the
condom broke that that was the one time
yeah tan tekonsha probably have included
a little plan being her good impact and
I need a plan B for this convention her
parents needed Plan B if I'm being
honest
yikes
so anyway turns out the con and tan akan
as quite a double meaning in this casing
as both a convention and a literal con
so I have a couple of bonus clips for
you guys it's there's really nothing to
say but I felt stupid even talking about
it honestly it's it's fascinating in
that it was such a train wreck in like
presumably they put this event together
almost without even a thought to what
would actually happen the day of you
know what I mean like yeah it's been so
irresponsible that I sent five thousand
[ __ ] people and almost did not even
hat like they thought as long as I
booked the room it's like you know if
you build it they will come
that was a movie
you need you need another audience out
there yeah I don't know you need anyway
it was just like mind-numbing ly insane
would not be surprised if we could we
see some jail time for them if I'm being
and I'm and I swear to god I'm being
honest or not be surprised well the big
thing is this Michael guy at least
according to Shane's documentary he
signed on the dotted line for everything
yeah but so he's he's definitely fun the
thing is I think she that one clip alone
proves that she has like a conspiracy to
commit fraud I love that for us that is
gonna play in a courtroom
oh yeah there's gonna be a judge and a
jury watching tannaz oh I love that for
us and then the judge is gonna be like
you know what I love for you
five to ten years I'm trying to think of
a good plan word I'm trying to you know
what I love for you Tana sixty five
months one month for every dollar for
your VIP ticket by the way bonus Oh in
my research I found some she's one is
why does she exist
why is she popular hey guys it's Tana
you know what's so stupid about like
YouTube like she like they complete I
know I haven't ran about YouTube but I
don't [ __ ] it I don't give a [ __ ] why is
it that YouTube will not even bat an eye
at me or idubbbz
or any of my friends that actually have
I'm not gonna say they have talent they
deserve shows what a [ __ ] is it always
Tana and people like her who are
actually not only the lowest character
but frankly criminals that get YouTube
read series like there was a she was
featured in this Joey Graceffa dog show
is so dumb the haunted house show God
have you
have you ever seen anything dumber
III dare you to watch this [ __ ] and yeah
in a way YouTube's enabling them to it'd
be like you are stars so they're running
ads for Tana I've got this ad a bunch of
times because she's premiered in the new
season of Joey Garcia's [ __ ] shitty
house and it says do you love Tana like
YouTube is actually running ads
promoting this this mom I say mom cuz
like I said it looks like she's going on
her second marriage she looks like a mom
that doesn't spend a lot of time with
her kids you know what I mean she looks
like a mom who's out at 3 a.m. partying
and grandma takes care of the kids you
know I mean does she not look like that
does she not look like this the odometer
is just about to hit a hundred thousand
you know the check engine light is on so
anyway and somehow I'm unendorsed below
or like my friends who who I respect who
make great content probably the best on
YouTube they're unendorsed but somehow
by anyway so I'm on her vlog Channel
right this is her trailer bro watch this
this is her trailer watch hunter and I
just took some adderall that's her
[ __ ] first message to her fans this
20 year old with these little girl fans
her first thing she wants you to know
about her is that she just took drugs
illegally I just took adderall could I
not say that she's brought she's
probably the one that left it on the
floor and two boys and shredders Oh
Oh interesting she got wind that we were
doing this today preemptive strike
let's give Tana a show on YouTube red
called how called how to be damaged
goods by the age of 22 let's let's give
Tana a shot a reality show on YouTube
red called how to poison the minds of
the young generation under the guise of
family-friendly content let's give her a
show let's do it
Oh Oh but kids like her let's give her
her shell kids watch her okay she's in
I just took adderall and I sprinkled it
on Heath ins Florida poison his dog who
I lost track of time how long did that
weed it's time for break I have one more
I have one more clip alright
and this clips not that important let's
go to the break alright I got worked up
I need to go cool off guys we've got a
commercial break and after that we've
got a lot to get to including we've got
prank calls that somebody did with my
voice someone made a sound board my
voice we've got I want to talk about the
ksi first Logan Paul fight so much more
ooh see you guys soon
[Music]
quip electric toothbrush legend has it
this toothbrush fell from the sky on the
eve of Jesus's birth Christmas Day this
shot from the sky like a meteorite but
it was not destroyed quip is the best
toothbrush ever invented by a mortal man
but the toothbrush itself is immortal
here's what it does it's electric it's
slick it's handy it vibrates but it's
just a little guy and guess what it only
costs you about 25 bucks to get started
with an electric toothbrush you put it
in it vibrates it cleans your teeth it's
got a nice soft bristle unlike any other
toothbrush I'm telling you folks do you
listen to the Angels crying they're not
singing they're crying because this is a
miracle that's why it's on Oprah's o
list nobody just gets on Oprah's list
here's what it does it vibrates and it
pulls Sates and it tells you when to
switch to the bottom side it times you
you're supposed to brush for three
minutes I bet you don't you sick nasty
freak your mouth stinks
not anymore brush brush brush vibrates
switch brush brush brush all the sudden
you're gone you brushed enough your gums
are healthy your mouth is glowing your
breath is incredible and those angels
that are crying for you right now
they're gonna be crying for the nice
smell in your mouth because finally a
girl's not gonna have to smell your
stinky breath and that makes angels cry
enjoy quip starts at just $25 if you go
to get quip comm / h3 right now you'll
get your first refill pack for read with
a quip electric toothbrush that's your
first refill pack free at GE TQ uip calm
/ h3 get quip calm / h3 get it so that
angels will cry for you
tears of joy you hear that
that's the sound of a suave ass Dollar
Shave Club using dude walking down the
street looking clean he's radiant he's
clean shave he smells good and everybody
who walks by says to themselves I want
to suck that guy's dick that's right
Dollar Shave Club folks Dollar Shave
Club delivers everything you need to
look feel and smell your very best you
name it shampoo conditioner body wash
toothpaste hair gel even a wipe that
will leave your tush feeling tingly and
clean and let me tell you folks when
they say tingly they mean it and I mean
that in the best way possible you want
your anal hole tingling I'm a big fan of
their amber and lavender calming body
wash this body wash is incredible have
you ever rolled through a field of
lavender
well it's thorny and it's awful and I
wouldn't recommend it but with the soap
you get that beautiful smell without you
know having to run to roll through a
bunch of brush it smells amazing
it's a beautiful thing good luck finding
a product like that in a store probably
cost you five to six thousand dollars
all of dollars shed clothes products are
made with top-shelf ingredients that
won't break your budget you will feel
the difference plus shipping is included
with your membership and here's a great
way to try a Dollar Shave club's product
for just five bucks you can get their
daily essential starter kit it comes
with the body wash the one wipe trolley
the their amazing butt wipes that's yeah
we talked about it the tingling
sensation on the anal hole I don't want
to saying
anal or the anus anal holds much sexier
than anus folks and of course the
world-famous shave butter
we got Wu's backstage folks and of
course the best raises the six blade
executive oh don't have my suit and tie
on but I've got my executive keep the
blades coming for just a few more bucks
a month and add in shampoo toothpaste or
anything else you need for the bathroom
check it all out at dollarshaveclub.com
slash h3 that's dollarshaveclub.com
slash h3 guys give it a shot it's
convenient come straight to your door
it's higher quality than what you find
in this store and it's it's two people
gonna want to suck hit me with that
music Dan and people when they pass you
on the street are gonna wanna Dan oh no
let's go that's it no that's it way too
long dude there's no reason not to join
get yours at dollarshaveclub.com
slash h3 today give it a shot if you
have not played for at night yet let me
ask you this what the hell are you doing
with your life this game is a phenomenon
taking the it's probably I think I'm not
sure but it's probably I think it's the
most popular game ever made the most
active players there's a hundred and
twenty five million players that's
insane that's like half the continental
United States you guys get on there you
might match up against ninja you know
the world famous eSports gamer that's
taken the world by storm here's some
gameplay right here this could be you
right now for tonight is a PvP of 100
players destructible environment
buildable structures and you can play
with your friends in duo's and squads
they are consistently releasing new
content and cool new features every day
that's true this game is always evolving
and being updated the developers cares
so much such a great polished fun
experience of a game there's a reason
it's so popular folks it's because it's
freaking awesome it's like the best
genre the battle you know the Battle
Royale
meets the best developers who have
completely polished it they're putting
so much love and care into it every day
what's not to love and here's the
craziest trivia sparked it's free it's
not 2% free-to-play yeah I know
for tonight's constantly did you guys
know that season 5 is right around the
corner
did you see the rocket that was launched
last week I wonder what that's all about
there's a rocket you better sign up to
play make sure you guys jump in before
season 5 starts on July 12th
and it's available on almost every
platform I'm talking I Oh s PC Mac
PlayStation 4 Xbox one and switch and
guys if I can't sing praises anymore
about fortnight it's frickin cross-play
like what game has ever achieved actual
cross play the meaning that if you're on
your PC you could play with somebody on
the PlayStation 4
what click the link in the description
guys to see what the hype is all about
play fight fortnight for free so go to
the link in description give it a shot I
mean what do you got to lose play for an
hour see if you like it if not delete it
it's free what do you have to lose thank
you for it and I appreciate you let's
get back into it
welcome to the experience can I get some
lightning bolts yeah
Joe Rogan step off [ __ ] that's right
you think I could take Joe Rogan an arm
wrestling match do you want a real
answer does he have lightning bolts Dan
yes or no oh I as far as I know no so
problem and the same answer as if I can
win oh I didn't know lightning was
allowed and I did I mean if it is then
you've got it in the bag no problem
alright easy let's get it here just like
the just like the store we saw
experience
that feels good just like the clip we
saw earlier of these Canadian crackheads
falling through the roof
there's another great one that I want to
throw up here this guy Lou Walsh okay
you creepy [ __ ] Looney tune this was
a clip I guess it happened several years
ago Lou Walsh from The X Factor I mean
we're all talking about like me too and
all this [ __ ] like if you if you blink
if you blink wrong at a girl you're
gonna be deposed Ethan answer truthfully
did you look from the your peripheral
vision down her skirt down her low-cut
top the camera caught you
your pupils looking slightly to the left
okay in this world I don't know if
that's a good example of whatever do you
guys give her look at girls through your
peripheral vision dan do like this I
don't think any guys already chickie oh
yeah I mean that's you do that I've
never I don't know that I can't say I've
ever done this really you've never come
on you see that girl anyway I think you
already went to sleep you can you can
tell the truth I mean I I don't but I'll
tell you who does Lou Walsh look at this
[ __ ] sicko this is the same show that
Ryan Seacrest was a bro what the [ __ ] is
wrong did you see his hand
[Applause]
[Music]
all right well she's clearly disgusted
she's not kidding around it how the hell
did nothing come from this like this
clipper surfaced recently of him
basically and by the way why do you have
to do it live on television is that
somehow like that the end the lines damn
theory right like safest and and in
plain sight yeah maybe it's kind of like
he's gonna say something to me that's
like the Seacrest thing to when he
approaches Katy Perry it's like why the
[ __ ] are you gonna make these creepy
comments to her right before you come
live cuz almost like this safest time to
do it right right because they don't
want to you know they're gonna cause a
scene by getting upset by it you know
it's there for ya what is wrong with you
like what is it it's clearly not sexual
assess vacation a really is almost like
a power play totally what's going on for
the for the audio listeners oh well yeah
oh yeah them both well he's sitting on a
couch during the live Brock is of The X
Factor he's got his hand on the co-host
ass he's squeezing it and patting it
live on TV she's getting noticeably
irritated and she finally says basically
what are you here why have a job like
that's a creepy show ever seen by the
way why is this guy look like a [ __ ]
baby why's his face look like a little
child that never aged to just he's like
his skin degenerated like he aged but he
never grew up that's you Lou Walsh Botox
right probably a lot of children's
foreskin you know they say children's
foreskin is the most regenerative potent
you know cosmetic you probably they say
that actually I'm not I'm not kidding no
I swear to God but I'll tell you Lou
Walsh this is a powerful man he's got a
lot of money
he's got the he's got the literal face
of a child he probably has baby foreskin
factory you know how they like a farm
silk
this guy farms foreskin he's probably
got babies on chains and he and they've
got super regenitive foreskin they're
like a new breed Wow
and they got a super regenitive foreskin
that he just snips and rubs actually
what he rubs is the smegma not actually
the foreskin but fish magma is the
residue and dirt collects when you don't
clean inside the foreskin not a problem
I have because I'm Jewish but he
probably does rub - magma all over his
[ __ ] face and that's why he looks
like there that's why it looks like a 50
year old Gerber baby I always hated that
guy's face yeah what a piece of [ __ ] and
he's like he's doing the groping and
then like the moment where she finally
reacts he's just like jiggling it it's a
man's world baby yeah why does this guy
still have a job that's my question cuz
I found this clip and it just resurfaced
I was like holy [ __ ] this is like really
bad and I'm looking and I'm looking and
I'm trying to find any evidence of him
being reprimanded for this and there's
enison there's nothing there other than
nothing we need to and we need to go to
his home we need to look in his basement
you know that there's like giant bottles
of like milk and these super regenitive
foreskin babies but in his basement he's
selling these to chinese patrons they
used them as viagra the Chinese will eat
anything to help stimulate their sex and
you know I'm right those [ __ ]
straight-up kill endangered species I
know who are baby to help get their dick
hard it doesn't work by the way but they
still kill them all and I'm sure you try
it don't knock it till you try it
rhino horn well as far as I can tell
there's no medical value and ground-up
toenails which is basically what it is
but I love that the Chinese to go on a
little tangent it's like you know that
there's viagra right you don't have to
go [ __ ] kill endangered species
anymore and Lou Walsh it's time to just
age with grace and shut down the baby
foreskin factory this guy pisses me off
man
it's pretty gross well when was this
this is like 14 you go yeah yeah some
you know that scarf you seen his
vest-pocket that's his [ __ ] jerk-off
rag such a sex up weirdo he probably
goes to the bathroom during the break
jerks into his rack puts it back in his
pocket he probably does weird [ __ ] like
makes her smell it without telling her
he goes it falls out of his pocket like
oh can you pick that up for me cuz he
gets off and knowing that she touched
his [ __ ] rag he's a sicko it's not me
[ __ ] this guy yeah [ __ ] this guy yeah I
guess this was this is pre pre Harvey
pretty late we're in a post Harvey world
and I just saw this video man and I got
to tell you I did not like it this is
the same show that like Seacrest Scott
and we're in weird trouble over though
right circle around Simon Cowell yes
Simon Cowell he is the like the
epicenter Simon Cowell is up to some
weird [ __ ] by the way baby foreskin is
just the beginning with Simon Cowell
it's just the tip of the day Simon
Cowell what is he do you know these rich
billionaires have the most [ __ ]
twisted like fetishes because like
nothing gets you off at that level of
wealth and power
what is Simon Cowell get off on hmm I'd
like to know he just beats people to
death for sport you just like grinds up
bodies and and then puts them into a
sausage tubing and [ __ ] himself with it
that's vulgar alright let's move on we
dissect it I think that's accurate
though just for the record look at his
face I wouldn't be surprised if he's
shoving you know body parts of his ass
what else would get along I get him off
does he react at all during this clip
like what what is his really keen I
think he looks disgusted
oh I don't know that he saw necessarily
right like I don't think he necessarily
knows everyone's joking around cuz they
didn't see how creepy was that's got to
be really frustrating for her she it
takes a lot of courage to on live TV and
be like hold on oh okay aha
yeah [ __ ] yeah and nobody saw what
happens it was hard to be like
supportive of her right in that moment
but yeah the couch don't necessarily see
how severe it is just god bless her you
know and yeah god bless her
that's all I can say all right [ __ ] no
let's move it on she's a spice girl in
my heart she's got a lot of spice she is
a spice girl it's confirmed confirmed
spice girl there so we announced a
giveaway last week for that a lot of
people submitted songs about Ian the
intern we got a lot of great submissions
but there was a one that really rised
above good oh [ __ ] I have to play it god
damn it can you play it yeah actually I
got already so there was one song that
really rised above made by Cage and
vacation it's a beautiful little ditty
that expresses my inner feelings on
eating the internet sometimes he's you
know he's there he tries his best but
god damn it in so god damn it Cajun
kujan I'm giving you what are you giving
them what is he beautiful s 9 plus oh
boy this is the best phone on the market
folks and let me tell you what I got a
special twist I got a special little
incentive god damn it didn't mean you
were supposed to pre oh yeah damn it it
opens this way oh there you go that's
all in my bed and you were supposed to
coach me on how to open this box and
this is the one that I'm this is the
this is it okay this is yours
comes with my DNA page engagement
Congrats you can you comes with my kiss
marks in my DNA so that's going out to
the Cajun Cajun and there's another
person I want to give a warden phone to
my favorite phone on the market by the
way Samsung has graciously supported us
they've given us what they send us ten
of these Dan and it's not really good
look at you notice this [ __ ]
beautiful new TV Samsung's hooking it up
and supporting us which is great because
they're basically my favorite tech
company we're gonna keep giving these
away what is this like a thousand dollar
phone give him answer what's what's the
retail value let's look at it a lot so I
am gonna give away another phone to this
is this one guy he submitted a prank
call that he made with my voice he
called a health food store and he made a
sound bored of my voice when I was
talking about keto diet and the call is
pretty good it's not like genius but I
love that he created this really
specific sound bored of me talking about
Cato and my hope is that by I want to
watch with you guys it's a lot of fun I
want more [ __ ] from you guys I want
sound boards I want prank calls
I want parody songs I want everything
cool send it goddammit to podcast at
h3h3 productions comm we're gonna show
it we're gonna credit you and our
favorite ones our favorite ones are
getting hooked up with my DNA that's
also on a Ness time plus you can choose
to not have DNA but I think most of you
are gonna want some of my baby foreskin
I am one of the super regenerative
babies imagine being a baby with super
regenerative foreskin Dilek escapes the
factory well your foreskin keeps [ __ ]
growing like it never stops oh wow you
have to cut it like toenails you have to
keep it a monthly bris it's a monthly
breast yeah did you know and this just
occurred to me and I think it's worth
sharing and this is real that in Israel
the very religious Jews have when they
have braces and please
I'm not kidding the rabbis I know where
this is going they suck the baby's
[ __ ] dick
they cut the foreskin off and then the
rabbi's suck the blood out of his newly
fresh [ __ ] dick hygienic and a lot of
the times these nasty old [ __ ] have
like herpes and they'll give the that
true yes what these guys are so insane
these old religious guys like they tried
to outline that that practice in Israel
recently but it didn't pass because
they're like listen if I want to suck a
baby's dick who are you to tell me no I
wonder if he's trying to suck the
regenitive for you know imagine imagine
for a second am putting a baby's
bleeding dick in your mouth are you not
going to imagine that just imagine being
that guy what the [ __ ] man oh here it
goes here goes nothing imagine the
insane these religious guys I'm telling
you man they're from another planet
entirely these the same kooky [ __ ]
there's some Jewish holiday where they
grab a chicken and [ __ ] spin it
around over their [ __ ] heads until it
like shits everywhere and it's just
spring [ __ ] everywhere and then when
they're done they go suck a baby's
bleeding dick these are the fringe by
the way this is not yeah yeah right this
is like they're out there yeah it's
basically like the Judaism version of
like the what's those lunatics that like
always causing a scene at like oh the
you know the something Baptist Church
yeah bro yeah Westboro let's see them I
like to see them square off saying the
insane battle who I think I gotta be
frank I think the Jews in this case win
you think so well they got the the
vitality from the baby
it's hard to top sucking a baby's
bleeding dick you can't really top that
and I and I feel bad even saying it
folks can I call you folks
anyway let's play the prank song so the
prank song by our the prank call by
sound master Tony go ahead and roll it
dance on master Toby here we go turn it
up
excuse me can I you help me with
something sure can you be kind and take
the time deposit to help me what are you
showing visually right now your
beautiful face that's gonna be awkward
what you want I guess I don't know but I
can't just sit here for two minutes I
was just showing them feel like just go
wide I like that yeah people have that
internalized oppression face okay I'm
gonna play I'm like excuse me can I you
help me with something
sure can you be kind and take the time
out of your day to help me how can I
help you I'm gonna be fully honest I
don't I stay in the keto diet
well the Akita diet is you know it's
like have you heard of the diet yes okay
so it's gonna be somewhat similar you
have to be in the same pattern of what
it is that they need you to do and then
they have their products that you can
that will help you lose weight this
whole thing I'm like don't eat fruit
just seems fishy to me oh maybe I'm
wrong yeah no back into this you know
it's kind of like you just eat a lot of
bacon and and meat you know nothing else
so okay for breakfast eat eggs and
cheese and bacon deep fried in coconut
oil
she doesn't bet a high she's like yep
that's the diet has been on that diet I
would recommend talking with him he'll
be back in the store on do you feel like
people hate fat people
no at the grocery store they're sugar
and [ __ ] everything well there is
it's so easy for skinny people like you
I crave and desire
Kirstin pizza well is it an issue of
self-control yes it is I've always known
that about you fat and skinny at the
same time I'm healthy at 400 pounds well
but if you'd like to talk you know talk
more with John about that diet you're
more than welcome to call back on Friday
I used to be fit okay are you actively
still on the decline
weight-wise are you asking me personally
yes well yes going I don't remember if
it goes anywhere I mean is that there's
not a climax necessarily so you guys get
the idea it's not a genius prank call
but I love that he sound boarded this
Kido thing and caught it he'll love it
I want your guys stuff help me be
funnier I'm not funny I don't have the
time to make segments you make segments
for us that's what I love genius and
frankly if you guys have a funny prank
call or maybe if it's not even related
to me necessarily we want to hear it and
if it's funny we're gonna use it and
we're gonna give you a freaking phone
not a bad deal so I looked it up it's
about 950 bucks
whoa whoa whoa you can eBay it I won't
judge you
you're not gonna want you though once
you open it up obviously all right oh
here's a good one this is a good one you
guys Tai Lopez friends of the show hmm
but I mean let's do this let's be honest
well I've said many many harsh things
about the lad throughout the years but I
just love this tie Lopez he's been doing
these live streams
and he's so cocky about it because he's
live he's like yeah I can handle
anything
give me a callin so he's giving these
these lessons on real estate and someone
calls in and basically calls him out and
shuts down Thai live on stream let's
enjoy alive what's up YouTube we're
doing a live debate I'm curious I'm
actually curious about your real estate
job all right so give me the formula for
a cap rate can you define what a cap
rate is so real let's talk about real
estate for a second let's - no no no no
define the formula cap rate do you know
what a cap rate is apps
he's like immediately trying to deflect
and for once this guy really holds him
to I don't know what the [ __ ] it is but
I assume it's probably some elementary
thing that if you know anything about
real estate you should know what this is
that's what I assumed absolutely
you crediting the channel Dan this was
made by Evan judge put together all
right could I say one thing on real
estate look at his face you can see the
humiliation his eyes are all squinted
he's just like Dan all the slickness in
the world sighs you've got your do you
understand Thai that your laptop is on
two books about Mark Twain and economics
on the bottom you really think you want
me to believe that you've read all three
of those books time Volume one and two
the autobiography of Mark Twain tell me
one was Mark Twain born tie and then he
goes let me tell you about Mark Twain
let's talk about how it Finn forces yeah
exactly who teaches my real who teaches
my real estate course John I don't know
oh so you don't know I don't teach my
real estate course I interviewed the top
real estate investors that I know
real estate how can you get started
[Music]
ty is honestly and as a as a guy it ties
honestly the master of [ __ ]
I don't the [ __ ] I just Club you let me
get that out there real quick he is the
master of [ __ ] mm-hmm
that was good man they held his feet to
the fire they got him good yep I want to
get him on here I want to call ty and
say tell me about Mark Twain give me one
more fact from the two volumes of Mark
Twain's autobiography ty give me a
freakin break I love Mark Twain I
wouldn't read that [ __ ] but that's just
me all right let's get to the pudding
the pudding pie we've got a key lime pie
it's fresh it's ready I would say maybe
an American apple pie warm out of the
oven good enough to put your dick in
it's apple pie American Pie kscypher
slogan pulp now I will say this I
actually like ksi I don't really have a
problem with this for you guys who don't
know logan paul yeah everyone knows it
logan Paul's case eyes are really big he
was got big playing Fifa but he's kind
of like the English PewDiePie in a way
he kind of just makes videos about
whatever he's very popular and he
recently had a boxing match with another
person who he won and now there's this
whole big thing about ksi boxing Logan
Paul my favorite part about this it's
such a circus I'm telling you I can't be
on YouTube it's this is what it's
devolved into there's nothing
genuine left with very few channels of a
genuine left
it's very anyway KS a little brother
comedyshortsgamer and the undercard
is boxing Logan Paul's little brother
Jake Paul
also a friend of the show yeah and also
friend of show so I don't I don't have a
problem I actually like those guys but
this whole thing is just such a circus
like let me show you
they haven't fought yet but here's the
the press conference from from the event
actually the volume on Logan Paul Europe
who are you like one minute you're mr.
suicide prevention and now you're mr.
sit your ass [ __ ]
sit your ass down [ __ ] the great white
help it's just a white boy from Rio I
don't know what that means there's a
movie called that I don't I don't know
if I just made some racial implications
so strike that from the record but it's
like who are you guys look at Logan and
Jake Paul like who the [ __ ] are you
there's nothing genuine about these
people they're flying in the wind they
don't know who they are these are the
people that YouTube selects to promote
and highlight and endorse and I don't
know what it is by Nature it's almost
like survival of the fittest on YouTube
it's like you have to be this authentic
oil slick that floats in the water to
rise to the top
it's very rare very few exceptions of
YouTube channels that actually rise
above and find success that are not this
[Music]
and let me let me say this so I'll just
I'll keep this running because I really
don't actually even care what they're
saying it's so obvious that they're like
pretending the
all right I want to even be surprised if
I'm being honest if these guys talked
regularly on the phone hundred person
just colluding you know to make this the
biggest event ever because their whole
thing is like this is gonna be McGregor
versa
may feels bigger that's how they're
presenting it
this is crazier I bet you these guys
talk on the phone and they just jerk off
about how much money they're gonna make
and on one hand I have to respect the
brilliance of like doing a boxing match
I think it is somewhat of a brilliant
move but it's like Logan you're not like
who the [ __ ] are you dude are you the
lovable child entertainer who cares
about suicide prevention or are you a
[ __ ] I don't even know what he looks
like he looks like he looks like a
door-to-door salesman who's going bald
at an early age yeah you know and this
is this is the moment they live for
where everybody's rushing onstage you
can't believe it oh the tensions are
high these two guys are gonna kill each
other they really truly genuinely hate
each other there I mean while like fast
forward to this morning at 8 a.m.
they're both on this unlike the toilet
amen it's gonna be great just we've got
it really get the high energy we got to
rush each other it's gonna be cool
everyone's gonna get freaked out you
won't play smash tonight they're like
best friends I don't know this whole
thing is so transparent who'd you uh
would you box the food I box like you
know because this whole thing with like
you know where's Bob each other who's
your matches I would box
I would box and what's this there's this
toy channel with this little kid it's
really popular
what's a toy channel
like little kid no there's really
popular one toy channel YouTube it's a
kid I imagine most of them are right
maybe not actually it's like Jay's toys
or some [ __ ] everybody knows what I'm
talking about
anyway there's this toy child they get
like 300 million views a month that's
just a little eight-year-old kid I would
[ __ ] beat this [ __ ] for all the toys
baby I can't beat up anybody and I fully
acknowledge that you know what I mean
I am I wonder I wonder how I we're doing
a fight like today like as an adult I
don't know I get my ass beat probably
you're gonna fight growing up yeah but
it's like you're a kid you're like me
you know resilient I don't know yeah I
beat the [ __ ] of a kid I mean most
definitely fries shove it up I think I
could take Jimmy Lee oh I'll pay for
that what do you mean Roy somebody just
said Roy in our chat Roy ela said Sheila
said Roy what are you doing up who's Roy
HeLa ILA's watch I think this is the the
toy Channel Roy toy Roy
it's not Roy she's help he was trying to
set up this match between me and Mae he
was doing work for me it was a chant for
staying up it was so late Orion Ryan's
toy review Ryan's toy review Brian I am
coming for you and I am [ __ ] pissed
it's going down um what's an adult I
could take Danny DeVito Jimmy is a he
for sure I feel like I could take people
Herman but he's a little crazy he's old
though he's Wiley I don't think he's
wild he's wild I don't think there's not
there's not many of us feels bad but you
actually gave me the clue I type Roy's
toys and it's
Ryan so he'll your are on top of it
tonight God who yeah anyway
let's focus enough about me cigarette
I'm gonna come out I'm gonna do this
whole bit making fun of the Japanese the
suicide forest and and rush me
notice when he'd then when they rush
each other by the way that he never
actually throws a punch they just like
collide and then everyone charges in to
do like this iconic like no they went
there no break it up break it up
hold on there's this one where they rush
the stage I have to find this maybe we
missed it ready it's here it's what the
[ __ ] is he doing I like it it was the
Nazi salute you see how you see okay
side charges in but doesn't actually
throw yeah great thank you looks like
what are you intending to do you write
of them what's a [ __ ] you gonna be bald
in two years Logan imagine Logan Paul
bald in like a Lamborghini like bald
like bald like not even like bristles
hey baby I prefer the horseshoe look
honestly hmm the old monastery Allah
yeah
imagine Logan Paul balding sitting on a
wagon cooking Mead like a monk that's
right it should be in a robe yeah with a
what - with like a you know controlling
the horse that's Logan Paul it's a
[ __ ] monk anyway it's just so I just
I'm sorry I think it's so funny I don't
think there's anything genuine I don't
think they have you know and then here's
the thing they're not you they want to
bring 20,000 people into an auditorium
it's like bro this is going to be
guaranteed the least entertaining boxing
match ever these are two youtubers not
trained professional fighters nobody's
gonna get knocked out it's going to go
the full distance of the fight because
none of them have the capacity
or the physical ability to knock each
other out they're gonna get tired after
two rounds there's gonna it's just gonna
be a bunch of tired ass dudes throwing
weak-ass punches at each other it's
gonna end in a judge decision and
honestly could go either way because who
[ __ ] cares at that point because you
paid hundreds of dollars to watch
essentially two untrained fighters throw
wet noodles at each other which is
basically all they're gonna be throwing
after two rounds do you think I mean
this is like you pointed out this is
obviously staged do you think the fight
is gonna be genuine in any way or is it
like wrestling it's not gonna be real I
think it'll be real because they both
want to win sure but I don't think
either of them can knock each other out
I don't I read genuinely don't you know
they're doing this twice there's like
another fight date in January yeah one
the first ones in the UK but then
they're doing a us one we should go I
hear you but I also think a lot of
people are gonna do that I mean maybe it
could be you know it would be fun I've
been wanting to plan a man on the street
segment maybe I've been wanting to do
something with Joey salads for some
reason where I'd send him like man on
the street so or maybe not even Joey
cells but maybe someone we actually
respect to go create like a segment you
know and play it on the podcast I mean
[ __ ] dude I think that's a great idea
and Ian you down you're down to go to UK
to go watch ksi versus Logan no it's in
LA I thought no I think well the first
one is in the UK okay oh that makes
sense I was wondering where they're
gonna do it in the UK cuz okay that
that's Indiana August 25th in the UK
second fight is scheduled for February
2019 in an undecided venue in the u.s.
probably la close and polish Bailey he's
fallen from grace I don't think he's
selling maverick merch his vlogs on
getting that many views do about a seven
million dollar house you know the
property tax on seven million dollar
house I mean you're looking at well it's
one percent so it's it's that seventy
thousand dollars a year every year
forever I'm sure that YouTube money will
keep rolling in right I yeah probably
but like to an extent but I mean when he
bought that house he was at his peak
yeah and now
we'll look what he's doing now I'm sure
he's gonna get paid handsomely but the
thing is III haven't watched other
people's reaction to this but hopefully
they also don't get taken in with like
there's a lot of details of like look
when a look when KS I told
comedyshortsgamer to chill look at all
these details oh look what that means
it's all a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ]
look in the crowd by the way all these
kids all right
I've talked enough about this honestly
I'm boring myself but there was one
funny details like wow they're they're
selling out this arena
it's the biggest sporting arena in
Europe apparently I read and I was like
wow I wonder I wonder how they're the
ticket sales are cuz the fight is coming
up pretty soon so I'm go to the seating
plan and I'm like holy [ __ ] there's a
lot of [ __ ] seats I scroll in here so
these were never opened these are closed
hmm and these are there's a lot of seats
available you know like these these are
quite possibly we're never opened I just
looked it up at 21,000 is the capacity
of that arena it doesn't even look like
they're at half of that yeah I don't
think so I mean it's it isn't that far
off next month I guess yeah I mean you
don't the ticket sales don't go up right
right what I'm gonna be looking at when
I watch that is I want to see the seats
I want to see well what usually what
they do is they like they'll try to fill
they'll pack it all in where the cameras
can see for sure like all these like
ringside seem filled but what is that
like 2,000 at most probably not even
that maybe a thousand mm-hmm that's
crazy
ringside seats man this fight by Pena
and sale apparently it's like $600 for
ringside nevermind sorry Anne that's not
my budget let me see the ticket prices
and [ __ ] cares I mean seriously who
gives a [ __ ]
so I don't know that's what I have to
say about that there you go there it is
just like Forrest Gump and that's what I
have to say about that yeah but nobody's
clapping for me you guys thank you thank
you thank you at least one person on
YouTube is genuine thank you I deserve
that
last week we spoke about Metamucil which
is what Chris this is what everyone's
been waiting for
really oh yeah it's 30,000 people
watching right now really for this for
this so it was recommended to me and I
bought it it's kind of expensive by the
way it's like 25 bucks for like 300
capsules and when you get the bottle it
says take five a day it's like these
huge pills were like Jesus okay I have a
day yeah I was like damn but then I was
like I'm not taking five another like a
horse
it's like a huge pill of like wheat like
yeah of course it's gonna clean my
bowels when I just eat a banana at that
point what rather you'd a banana well
anyway I take two pills and this is a
night where I'm going out to a party and
for dinner I have pizza and I have
alcohol now for any mortal man any one
of us this would result in an absolute
catastrophe total wasteland okay of the
anus an [ __ ] area frankly sometimes I
[ __ ] so disgusting when I have diarrhea
it sprays on my thighs and I'm not gonna
lie well sometimes it happens it's real
sometimes I mean sometimes you blast in
Italy you know hits the side of the of
the deflection I see I just thought you
were like a shotgun blast and it was
just yeah why no it's a buckshot and
sometimes you see you sometimes I'll be
when I have a meal like this
wiping as I do this way don't [ __ ]
hate on me there were men by the way
Ian fest up he's a front to back what
he's a back to front you know when when
you guys were arguing about it on air
Ian and I were arguing about it back
here you know I got to say to I I was
curious
that night I went home and I tried it
your way and I gotta say it's inferior
it's not a fear you you're not used to
it if I tried it your way wouldn't
respond I have years decades of
experience wiping it's muscle memory Dan
yeah well you will you expect to go home
and just a try live live one evening in
my [ __ ] and you think that's that's
Dan you you don't know you're talking
about I should give it another shot and
fret and frankly I'm I'm in the middle
of something all right I'm talking about
my shotgun diarrhea so the verdict is
still so you ever have a [ __ ] so nasty
like you wipe and then you're like I
better check my thighs and cheeks just
to be safe
sometimes that's reality for me and this
was one of those meals so I take these
pills I took two of them not five before
I go out because we only have [ __ ]
humans garbage disposal what am i taking
five it's a little ridiculous and I have
to say the next morning I had the [ __ ]
just slid out of my [ __ ] with
elegance and grace and a supple a supple
glide almost that as if to say hey you
know it's gonna be okay Wow and and I
went to wipe and I wasn't a one wipe
there was it was some but not a lot I
would say was a threeway I don't
necessarily have the courage not to end
with a wet one I ended wet because I
mean that's just part of who I am but I
was I was shocked I was absolutely
shocked by that first day result I was
blown away but since then I've been
taking it every day with my Neil and I
have to say I'm not I'm still not
totally sold because
it's it's all it's a weird thing like
it's like greases your [ __ ] it like
slides out of your [ __ ] like somebody
sprayed you know spent like Pam on your
a is like it's just cool it's great it's
like a not it's like a it's like your
anus it's like your intestines is made
of Teflon it's kind of a strange
phenomenon upfront being on it it just
slides right out
Wow I wasn't curious before but now that
you've explained the Crisco ass no I
swear to God if you if you try these you
will experience a difference in bowel
movements so it on the bottle it says it
can take up to seven days for your body
to adjust to actually getting fiber for
the first time in its life so I mean I
mean John I am enjoying it so far and
I'm gonna I'm gonna keep reporting back
but it's it's real interesting but it's
a mixed bag you're saying like if it's
not no after that initial no no it's
been pretty good it's good it hasn't
gotten better because I was like wow I
had pizza and alcohol and my [ __ ] was
this clean but I've had good days and my
[ __ ] wasn't better than that
you know what I mean mmm which is what I
was expecting so all wrong I'll keep I'm
gonna keep taking it like I mean I enjoy
it I enjoy having my my [ __ ]
basically you know like I said like a
slip and slide essentially you know the
slip into the hides away but do you know
the ones where you hit the end and then
you splash up and splash out Gramp got
like an alligator's head it's like that
so I like it alright I'm gonna have to
give it a shot I'm gonna sell so much of
these [ __ ] Metamucil man that where's
my sponsor hit us up bear whoever it is
to them away I wrote a song for ela me
and my friends wrote a song for Yili
since she's gone and I'm Sam's the
Wizard of loneliness as I've previously
coined
we'll get to that at the end but let's
see I've got the whomp-whomp clip let me
let me play this really fast cuz I love
it so much I mean look I read today
about something I don't I don't like to
talk about politics that much these days
but oh my god this is this is special
folks this is this is special I mean
look I read today about a ten year old
girl with Down syndrome who was taken
from her mother and put in a cage I read
about a I read of a of a girl with Down
syndrome being put in a cage womp womp
she's so [ __ ] priceless crazy it's
just so bright girl with Down syndrome
who was taken from her mother and put in
a cage I read about a yes that's what he
said politics is such a [ __ ] show I love
it it's such a circus this is basically
comparable to ksi of our slogan Paul
right now except with like little little
kids did you just say womp womp you bet
your [ __ ] ass I won't pump - and that
little girl with Down syndrome so
unabashed taken from her they put in a
cage I read about it god bless him Dan
had a funny note about this he said this
is Corey Lewandowski Lewin down
Lewandowski are or as you might say
Lewin against down skis Oh
how am I not hurt that's - that's do
good well done well done
Corey lewandowski's it was Trump's 2016
campaign manager until he was replaced
by Paul Manafort who is currently in
jail so this is a roof this is a winning
look at the winners this is the office
you want to hold Lewin Det Lewin against
down skis refused to apologize for the
remark when asked about it on Fox News
whomp-whomp I just it cracked me up I
was just like oh he
womp-womp the [ __ ] Down syndrome baby
crazy it was how cuz this I've got this
Jimmy Lee clip I guess I might throw it
on and then I want to play this song for
all you guys I got a song please I want
you to watch it so don't go away this is
very important to me and to my friends
who wrote it with me and to ela and to
shredder who almost died today maybe I
should just play it well that's gonna
take us out right do we need to say
goodbye no I'm gonna watch Jimmy Lee
okay first it's really not much to say
about our old friend Jimmy Lee is up to
some antics that I find pretty funny
what are the numbers that how we doing
doing good 20:29 29.5 nice welcome
everybody thanks for tuning in
god bless you appreciate you so very
much Jimmy Lee the jersey outlaw he's
still at it he's dangerously funny you
guys remember Jimmy Lee probably he's
like this incredibly racist abrasive
unfunny just really a character and the
worst way possible
we had him as a guest it was one of the
worst episodes we had him at as a guest
and after our first break meet Dan and
ela were huddled in the corner he was
outside and we're like good we can't
this can't go on we have to end them so
he actually gave them the the the
cartoon cane off the stage it's frankly
it's our fault I think that we should
have anticipated that this would have it
was a formative experience for us we
didn't really know what we were doing at
the time but it's fine it was those
early days but anyway he started hew
budding he doesn't actually have an
engaged audience but this video has 1.2
million views 94 comments and 900 likes
so he started viewbotting which I find
you know pretty pretty terrific let's
look at the comments Jaime you're my
father
I don't think a YouTube video has ever
made me laugh so hard Oh cheers to you
literally couldn't finish this one made
it halfway and stop to cringe
well anyway let's let's give you a taste
of this viral hit Jesus can you mix your
[ __ ] audio all right so the video
starts well that you watch for yourself
the video starts with five seconds of
blank so the video begins with them
having crowds of people pretending to
know who he is which is a phenomenon
I've noticed you know springing in his
videos it's a part of his plan to
viewbot I guess is that he's he's
building this great story about himself
he's got security guards by the way
every year he's like my new hit series
is hitting spring 2017 spring 2016 it's
like man we are all waiting for that hit
big breath can't wait
[Music]
yeah that's a lot of enthusiasm you got
it for them well what are you the
president you've got like Secret Service
with earpieces and [ __ ] I can't watch
this I just thought it was funny I
thought it was like damn Jimmy still
trying anyway you got to give it up till
told Jimmy let you know what let's watch
a clip let me know let me don't cut them
off let's see some of this comedy most
people don't recognize you what else to
talk Jimmy this what happens when your
parents beat you up as a kid he's like
am i right to the guy so let me every
cowboy Brett zoom in zoom in no well
you're doing it daily or weekly
and will you quick quick or did you take
your time and draw funny stuff folks
funny really all right anyway we're
putting our audience in danger so even
we think we've seen enough if you guys
want to go through current I want to say
cringe afterlife okay Jimmy Lee shot
he's a friend of the show he's a great
guy I hope to hear from him soon I'd
love to get him involved in some kind of
segment you know dude Jimmy Lee is a
true like like goof spoofer I'm trying
to think of like a wat back did we ever
settle on a whack-bat name for us there
was the gaff pack yeah I was I was
partial to get thing I like gas back
yeah he's a he's an original gaff packer
all right well I gotta say I hope the
show was okay
I felt like I was bombing in here
especially the first half you're doing
fine
because you start sweating there's
nobody in here to I'm like oh my god you
know it's tough without ela and that's
why me and my friends we started playing
music were called the jokes last time
either was gone we started working on
this song called gold mine and now that
heel is gone we finalized this it's a
beautiful tribute to ela client my
better half I miss her and I love her so
that being said this is the world debut
of the jokes and guys I will see you
next Friday at the regular time with
beau Berman I'm so excited for that and
I hope you enjoyed the show with that
being said play us off
[Music]
where I can't call your needle that long
night feels like years make and be with
you between my ears
[Music]
without you and I'm so blue
and a goldmine
[Music]
you so come
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
without you unless you're bout a stone's
throw a goldmine
without you I just want you
[Music]
sunrise it just me listening the head
goes without company
a sunset lights out it's all fools gold
man you're not
worth having
without you and I'm so cool
and a goldmine
[Applause]
without you so come his heart
[Music]
without you unless you're bout a stone's
throw
without you
I just want you
[Music]
I tap the vein the vault is full I had
the Midas touch but it's old fool's gold
without you
[Music]
without you and I'm so blue
[Music]
without you so come though when it's
hard
[Music]
without you I just want
[Music]
[Music]
you